this is max greenfield from the
neighborhood i'm here with buzzfeed and
today we're going to read some
uh thirst tweets i had to ask what a
thirst tweet was
the fact that there's any tweets like
this on the internet it's nice to know
that people are thinking about you
hey buzzfeed celeb please let max
greenfield
read thirst tweets so he knows that all
of my dreams consist
only of him feeding me jelly beans
thanks
it's all right feels pretty kid-friendly
so far so good
max greenfield smile clears my skin
improves my mood and raises my gpa
this is these are all very good for my
self-esteem i'm having a good day
reading these
if i could meet a guy like leo d'amato i
would absolutely decide to settle down
and become as the kids say a wifey
okay max greenfield's jawline is a gift
from god
literally well it depends on you know
what your spiritual preference is
and how you view the world but it's
really all a gift from god truly
not just my jawline everyone's jawline
when will we be recognizing max
greenfield
as the white boy of the year appreciate
it i play the white boy of the year on
the neighborhood
i would pet max greenfield's head all
day if he let me i don't know about all
day
max greenfield smile is a deadly weapon
alright
watching new girl wondering when i'll
get a sexy jewish
boyfriend like schmidt well i think a
lot of people wondering that
maybe i don't know max greenfield's
thigh is appreciation post
well i pre that one i really that one
makes me feel good i do a lot of squats
i work a lot on my legs
not a lot of upper body stuff i want to
lick max greenfield
head to toe uh i guarantee you don't
i don't know how to describe the fact
that max greenfield
played young sandy cohen on the oc any
other way
than as the horniest casting choice of
all time
like wow what a gift horny is an
underused word
losing sleep fantasizing about how
schmidt
from new girl would be handling this
bussy is that right oh right on i just
found out what a bussy is
and uh really appreciate it i'm honored
i feel like this is a safe space so i
need to have a threesome with nick
miller and schmidt
there i set it and i feel better it's
gonna be a tough sell for
jake johnson can max greenfield murder
my
busy murder's a strong word
veronica mars should have at least sat
on leo's face one last time
just one gal's opinion well look i don't
write the shows
buzzfeed i just want to say thank you
for compiling
um all of these thirsty tweets about me
um it's something i would not have done
on my own so i appreciate the experience
and a lot of them were just compliments
except for the stuff about the busty
what a day this was i'll never forget it
please check out the
neighborhood mondays at 8pm on cbs
you